there's an atmosphere of peace in
Khartoum pigeons not bullets are flying
in public squares outdoor time much
cherished here is back even book sales
are improving says Kemal Pamuk he's been
in the business for 30 years but civil
wars and state censorship have kept his
sails down Kemal is skeptical about the
new Political Agreement it doesn't meet
the aspirations of the people especially
the young few former regime leaders are
being held responsible for their actions
a young generation was underrepresented
in the talks what's being done may well
lead to a reproduction of the crisis
this man is even more vocal it's too
early to celebrate protests need to
continue our revolution is hijacked
through soft landing agreement by
political entities that jumped on the
bandwagon at the last minute and took us
into talks of a power shearing the
process is also conducted by Western
powers they brought people with zero
knowledge about Sudan to rule us I'm now
standing at the center of all Khartoum a
place seemingly frozen in time with zero
progress since colonial days only it's
filled with a new generation people born
in destitution and amid crises under the
regime of Omar Bashir now that he's gone
they are impatiently waiting for the
fruits of change
[Music]
from chance of violence - quiet national
songs they save for now they want to
continue the struggle through different
means without ruling out the likelihood
of returning to the streets with
unemployment between 20 and 30 percent
they young have little to do about
monetary developments
many say they like the new prime
minister who was appointed after a
power-sharing agreement between the
military and protest leaders they hope
he'll fulfill his promise to bring about
solutions some of the people who have
been appointed or okay it's a first step
if they just stick to their announced
plans things will improve they need to
meet our demands we're still under the
control of members of the Islamist
movement the deep state is intact and so
is the security apparatus these views
are not denied by some of the very
partners of the agreement the the
problems are enormous
you know have the legacies the whole
legacy of the past system 30 years of
corruption inefficiency we're closed
which we see land you know we're about
to dock despite the skepticism many
Sudanese share the hope of a new land of
promise but they know that if it happens
it's going to be a slow and difficult
road ahead mohammad van al jazeera
Khartoum